I'm currently at 440 pounds uh I was
diagnosed with severe sleep apnea should
I stopped breathing like 64 times an
hour which is insane you got my little
machine now so I'm getting that right
trying to get my eating right with the
keto and the whole good thing but I've
had this Peaks and valleys of how I've
gone up and down with my weight
struggling with food so I guess you know
it might be a good person to ask how do
I keep my emotions in track
so I continue to make good decisions and
how can I actually make this work so I
make a lifestyle change forever you
can't let your emotions dictate what
you're going to do well it's kind of the
conversation we just had because I mean
if you think about it motivation is
really just an emotion right it's just
an emotion you feel really good and
motivated you can't let your emotions
dictate your actions yeah you've got to
let your your logic dictate your actions
and hey it's not going to feel good
every day I just this morning I I I
didn't feel like working out I was sore
I've been working it hard for the last
few days I did not feel like working out
at all and I went down there and I went
through the motions and and you know
what
you know people say you're just going
through the motions I was like yes I was
but that's better than not going through
the motions because I got down there
right I did the work it wasn't the best
workout I ever had no records were
broken nothing was crazy but I went down
there and did what I was supposed to do
there was no motivation involved
whatsoever zero right I was unmotivated
I was motivated to to to just snuggle
into bed yeah but no yeah so don't let
your don't let your emotions dictate it
and Peaks and valleys guess what that's
what life is yeah what life you're gonna
have you're going to have times when you
feel good you're gonna have times when
you feel bad
and you can't let those things be so
broad spanned so that you can't let
those Peaks be so high and those valleys
be so low that it throws you off course
when I feel down it's like okay you know
what that's going to pass yeah and the
way you make it pass is through action
it's what you just said yeah you said
you know when I get going that's when
I'm good that's the same thing to Jason
hey Jason if you're not feeling like it
you know what do what Theo does just get
stop that stop the thinking about it and
just go and go for the walk go get on
the treadmill get whatever exercise
you're gonna start doing start doing it
and the other thing is look man this is
a long War this isn't a battle that
you're gonna fight one day two days
you're in a campaign yeah in a campaign
World War II four years of combat to get
where you want to go maybe seven years
maybe eight doesn't it I don't know but
part of you don't have to think hey if
only I could be at the end man enjoy
where you're at right now yeah I know it
sounds crazy but you know you said dang
trapped in man you're lucky you're lucky
you know I got friends that have been so
severely wounded yeah you know they
can't go for a run they lost their legs
they lost their arms they lost their
Vision whatever hey man you're you're
you're good to go you're good to go go
out yeah and like you said live
yeah I think it I mean that's yeah I
mean it's that's it it's like you you
gotta keep you have to get moving
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one